Bing hey there welcome to this week's
Android developer office hours from
Google London
I'm Richard Hyndman devlins de new
butcher Chris Bane's are all here to
answer Android development questions and
dairy talk about Android developer
topics this week
welcome to the people who have joined us
in the Hangout Johanna
of course Paul Hanson as well and Avenue
is hey 385 be fine so we're gonna start
this week's show off with a little
announcement and we are this is gonna be
the last of the Android developer office
hours we're taking a break for Google
i/o which is now 28 days away is coming
very very quickly very quickly for
anyone who's got to write a presentation
get rehearse so yeah we're we're taking
some time to UM focus on Google i/o
there will be all heading out to
Mountain View soon for rehearsals and
all that sort of good stuff so it's
gonna be hard to keep the show running
through that period we will be back
after i/o 1 we should have a brand new
studio here in London so everything will
be a bit more professional you might
have to turn the lights down into this
grainy level to make it not look super
bright and heavy Chris won't be able to
pull the power so going to come back
with a new show after Google i/o so um
these last 25 minutes Android developer
office hours for for this month I guess
so
go on will kick off see if anyone in the
Hangout as a question question I want to
create a widget but I only have I can
only do pull to the server for
information and of course with the
widget you have to well keep the
refreshing minimum I don't know I was
like 30 minutes or an hour watching
advice is there still a way to maybe
with with its service to an oak tree can
we pull the backend service and notify a
widget to update or do you have any
experience with with that kind of
scenario is the data going to be you
gonna know when the data is ready on the
server dating frequently
basically it's a music player so to
speak but we don't have a two-way
communication it's only one way so the
GCM to go from your server to our
servers will notify the device to do an
update no no no a bright area server so
it's running some Linux or pool or
whatever so I don't have any influence
on that support so I can pull the server
for information but there's no way the
server is going to communicate that to
me when it's so much next one is playing
or whatever so yeah so you could say you
sitting on the device but it sounds like
your best bet it's gonna set up some
kind of another suicide like things are
like an app engine project or something
like that to pull it and when something
has changed then Tokelau GCM servers and
will deliver a message serve device to
let's see then updated with it it is the
way to the otherwise you're going to
seem to gonna have a service running
holding the option then trying to off
device because it's gonna destroy the
battery em check burritos talk from last
year last year's i/o he had some good
tips on that because if you're polling
every five minutes it's gonna keep the
radio on like maximum power and crazy
things like that so those tips and about
battery usage and holding if you have to
do it okay thanks Hey
we use a successfully the Google Drive
API rather than one in our application
few days ago we found an update using
the Google the Google API plugin for
Eclipse and then this appropriated to
version two okay starting the update to
the Google Play Store and about the
three percent of our worldwide users
they are experiencing invalid to file
corrupted corrupted the only change that
we have done just update is API and then
republished
apk and now they are getting anything
from the Google Play Store they are
getting valid file do you have any
suggestion anything that I can check
I've seen this happen once or twice very
rarely before and the Google Play Store
is cached throughout the world at
various cache servers and occasionally
afoul it does appear that if our may get
corrupted on one of those servers and
the best way to resolve the issue is
just to republish the application again
into the Play Store I've seen it happen
a couple of times I've had people
mention it and when they republish all
the caches get played again in flash and
it goes through and then it all starts
working version number and spit on you
Sunday because the quickest and easiest
way to get around the problem if that
fixes it then fantastic I guess it will
it'll also be in some operators catch
somewhere it may not be in one of our
caches you know these apk files are
quite large and people catch a lot of
stuff on the mobile Internet Richard the
why beat happened just to a few
customers and not to everyone if it the
file is corrupted on the Google server
one Google so every will be corrupted on
a cache somewhere on the internet it
could be on one telco operator server in
one country for one group of people
often you'll see that you get clusters
of people who suffer from this issue at
one time though and the easiest way to
get around it is to just republish it
may not even be in our content than
every Network it could be somewhere
outside
I've never debug to do not to find out
exactly where
system these corrupted files okay so
this this problem is not the first time
all they did you you had some experience
about it
yes third time I've had someone now
mentioned that a group of users are
getting a corrupt file I got it it's the
Playstore here and never have we been
able to find a corrupted file on our
system so I'm guessing it's outside of
our network but who knows mmm-hmm thank
you very much thank you very much I got
it yes sir Andy from India as mom asked
he put webview memories not garbage
affected is there any way to do that
thank you
and what I'm not exactly sure what you
mean by that
yeah which bin I think yeah I remember
there were some issues with some time
the webview keeping the reference sort
of her activity and the garbage
collection was kicking I was peeking in
at a later time I think we had a similar
similar problem but I think we try to
set everything we even queried the
parent activity and what we're setting
everything to no but but then we we
didn't had really a solution for it but
I know it is this has happened to us too
one thing I found actually today he said
there's a destroy method I want you
which party it's all four moves or if
you use tracing schools and dump the
memory you will see that you still have
that you still lead the activity because
they live so basically yep if he destroy
on put it on the wiki but did not
release the activity right I think it
was not happening but it's it's one year
ago so it I don't know if it's a bug in
the framework but I'm just saying that
I've experienced something like this
before with tivity was leaked in was but
we didn't Kim it sounds like you can
adjourn again we have problems with this
if you have multiple multiple web views
so trunk condensing down I guess other
place which we can do to me one no yeah
so Ivy Dewey
ofE nice apology for as Iran why was
there an introduced a 4,000 character
limit on text to speech right and ice
cream sandwich the test feats service
and honestly I don't really know but I'm
guessing is do marecus Frances you
imagine that you have a four thousand
characters which is quite a lot actually
it's good paragraph two paragraphs to be
able to into speech ran wise I'm
guessing the fort would behind it was
that you have to split you up myself and
then sort of do it on demand as you
finish your speech request another four
thousand Carter doesn't use the
conversation thing as well we can just
keep on talking and it keeps up the
constant dictation so maybe typing
keyboard so maybe they're using that
thanks to speech and maybe it's just a
friend you from from making errors
because sometimes you just passing in a
string and you maybe something
interesting is that previously this
splitting was done inside the speech
engine I've checked the source code for
the oldest
api's and on pre honeycomb the splitting
was done inside the speech service
regardless of the size but now it's a
bit more complicated because we'll have
to delete the text and pass it after the
first one and so on and this actually
made to work with the speech serve is a
bit complicated than it was before and
if he looks at the changes on that
sideways on the splitting
is there any comments in the committee
explain why the limit was introduced hmm
I did I saw the comments I just checked
the source code I think I also posted a
link on the question so my guess of why
they changed it from splitting it in so
framework and to my user instead is so
you can split it on an end of a sentence
and running the paragraph so you're not
doing text-to-speech and then you have a
random word at the end so you can do
more contextual sort of that makes sense
you know much more about the content
than we do so you can probably make a
more intelligent break I imagine that's
it yeah okay okay yeah that's me this is
just off but yeah check out if you found
the place where the spinning goes on if
you look in if you go to and the Google
code repository which has all the
commits history and so on then you
should be able to see the reason why
they changes introduced you've been the
commit history
hopefully okay okay thanks thanks yeah
thanks the question just cuz we've got
quite a lot more viewers now than we did
at the start I'll um I'll really state
the other thing I said at the start that
this is gonna be the final Android
developer office hours we're gonna stop
this now once we get through Google i/o
and then after Google i/o we're gonna
have a new studio here in London we're
going to come back with that a new shot
vengeance vengeance any more like
Cushing's or she'll crack on her is
there a Bieber fever nearly tattooed
fever oh yeah I saw that I see this
first of three tattooing ever get this
so Juliano from Brazil has asked when
will you release the new updates of
Google Maps Android API version 2 and
why don't you open source the API so we
can fix it ourselves well obviously it
still needs to be pushed out to every
single device with the Google Maps API
on it so fixing yourself wouldn't help
too much and we always provide code
right so Google you know
Maps isn't an open source project Google
Maps is a you know Google proprietary
project so that's the reason it's an
open source like feel free the best way
you can contribute is by firing bugs
like use the public bug tracker and we
do check all the bugs there m/sec one
updates already been shipped for the
maps mm-hmm you know there are other
bugs hopefully Rahl gets those as well
but yeah for bugs and so Paul from
England has a stir with you how can I
work with it to know where page does it
get or post requests and see the headers
and deal with sort of redirect requests
and a few Ashley can I couldn't I look
for the API sort the deep down the web
UI beyond and I couldn't find a way of
actually getting to request it's all
done deep down into WebKit hey just
override the URL loading yeah that's
that that's in closer you can get is
override URL but you can't get this to
the actual physical requests so you have
to implement your own browser exactly
you have to sort of use patchy or URL
connection until we sell so you could do
that you could override the URL and then
was that you from England
nice
all right next question let's move on
carousel
dear guys as you know gallery was
deprecated viewpager item has a new
property to display free items but could
your voices and the carousel components
I found many which were sent from
gallery so can you do a horizontal
ListView
yeah this is a question we've seen this
before so essentially a lot of people
want gallery type behavior but with
gallery being deprecated I want to use
it and so the advice on our talk say
either to use a horizontal scroll view
or to use a view pager so horizontal
scroll view will just give you the
scrolling behavior and but no it's not
an adaptive view so you know it's not
gonna be very good for you know
extremely large data tests and pay per
view pager is great and I'm not sure you
mean by the free pages thing I think
you're talking about set partial page
width so that you can set page website
so you have more than one item on screen
but the problem with that is that it's
always left aligned so you're never
gonna get that centering type behavior
that you get with gallery so if that's
really what you want you can either use
gallery or you could use view page and
do some modifications to it to try and
get it to to Center and have like the
edges peeking in or whatever the
behavior might need to do but
essentially you missed a bit at work I
mean just because galleries defecate as
many can't use it and also I've seen the
plenty of implementations of gallery
which sort of add recite view recycling
Thanks and there's a lot on get up and
stuff so just have a go go and see and
you know also some libraries that use
horizontal scroll three is referred to
the fact that a few page reports while
the current
the current page of portion that the
previous in the next in cash or that
might be the three I don't know hmm all
right as well yeah next and she ends ax
as asked I want to refresh a web view in
line and in brackets he put have new
content without the white flush your
honor lash what my options I'm open to
faking it
yeah
waste memory yeah we've had the white
flash question quite a bit as well right
go native is the answer it sounds
flippant but yeah webview is an out of
the box component and it has certain
limitations and if you're butting up
against those then it might be your only
option and yeah if it's only a small
amount of HTML in that text views can
process some HTML so you like to do it
so it takes you inside instead of
webview a lot less ever had to use the
text view with a just a formatting is
not from HTML for a tentacle we could
always so expose JavaScript methods and
soft call them through open your Oh hmm
so the JavaScript within the edge web
page updates the page just do a lot of
testing so another library question a
winky Wang as a C's in hell and is there
a library for Android that can make the
same effect as page fall for iOS if
there's no should write one yeah so I
know the Google Books application does
this and that was all written using
render script to make it all love
informants ran script is open source not
the Google Books one but we do have a
page turning render script as open
source to you did it's the flat line it
doesn't have the page corner curling but
does the flat lines learning this in the
ripples which you look at in the SDK
samples it's not quite as good as the
Google books question but it is a good
starting point me yeah updated of course
using scripts
okay because the new joiners welcome
everyone who's joined us any questions
from the live participants just speak up
or you can use the sidebar and we'll
read it out if you want to type it in
instead if you don't heard Mike or
anything so - MA from Hungary is asked
I'm gonna para Pfizer questions they
swallow what's the best way again the
contact photo from a Content contact URI
he mentions that you can actually use
salt pasty all right with you or is it
best to use an open contact photo input
stream and get the input stream and I
said that the best way he's actually
using input stream because then from the
input stream you can have closer control
over how the actual bitmap is decoded
cuz you might only load it you might
want to use it in sample size or
something like that to have a much
faster smaller bitmap exactly so you can
use own in my factory to actually decode
the input stream to how you want and
that's it really I always go into the
stream of you all right to go for place
control and if you want to look at using
those in sample size and so on where can
you learn about that and there are a
number of NIT there there's a lure of
our new ish bitmap training class called
managing bitmap memory which decrements
all these as well as some techniques for
caching on that coaster all that
goodness and that was added last month
have a look at it there's no point
opening a massive contact photo which it
can be just to scare it down you may as
well open it using Australia only load
what you need that's got a come question
give me a spoon please go for it
was that a question is he face she's
he's moving yeah he holding very still
have we phrasing sorry Oh hangout so I
was trying to use number of picker from
both Android 4 and Android to this
trying to have application in it's a bit
of a hassle and I ended up having to
copy the entire number pick it from 2 to
my application and use that one because
you try to use there are some methods
that are change their signatures in for
Android
I think the API level 11 or something
and so is there any strategy that you
would recommend for such things
not really me I'll be working on this
kind of stuff recently got a lot it's a
compatibility and the best way is to
just drag the source into your source
file in TESOL straight because you have
a control over it and there's no nice
way of doing it because the trouble that
kind of stuff as well you have to drag
in all the styles yeah yeah and it
becomes a big problem but there's no
easy nice way of doing it unless you
still find a library that already has a
I assume someone's pretty late
unnecessarily but yeah there's no easy
way here unless you find a library she's
already done the work okay yeah but
probably the work would be the same yes
so you use the the the new version of
the number picker and an older app and
if Ike was compatible way you're saying
yes if straight-4 if you run your
application in Eclipse everything is
fine and you try to run it in the end
right to device it will crash because it
comes find a class and the class is
there with the signatures is different
so the first logo doesn't
I used the number pickers in the
ultimate stopwatch and I just API check
it and then use their thinking should
the right ones for two point three and
they're the new ones Ice Cream Sandwich
so if you look at the ultimate stopwatch
your source code
yeah will do
it's open source there and you can see
the way I did it I just used you have
the two separate chunks of code to make
the two different of the Pickers work
yeah that's more or less what I need and
you didn't if check on it are you
finding that from Android to upwards you
can have code for newer versions as long
as you execute it in the older versions
you can have it just API can't it in
there
or you can have two different concrete
implementations and just instantiate the
right one depending on yeah yeah but at
a certain point you have told this that
if it's one game to use yeah but just
target Ice Cream Sandwich okay all
righty right we've got too long we had
too much left
which one stood here is one here so CN
as asked how can we become a top
developer our F is over seven thousand
seven hundred thousand downloads and I
rating of 4.4 well congratulations
that's pretty dang good stats do you say
well the application is now he doesn't
uh yeah we get a lot of people asking
about top developer you haven't issued
all that the player tutorial team
haven't issued any new top developer
badges in them it must be every year now
cuz we were talking about it I Oh
last year the yeah the whole program is
kind of still on hold
yes they're trying to figure out what to
do with it I don't have too many details
on it but there haven't been any but
even before that they kind of guidelines
what you have like a string of very good
applications like normally multiple
unless you're you know a service which
was only ever gonna have one application
right and so yeah normally one app one
gap isn't you know sufficient you know
we had to have a string of apps
yeah the program became a bit fragmented
they definitely used it for things like
banks as well even if the apples aren't
high quality they used it to put the
tick next to
like a bank so you think it was the
trusted application and very light and
verified so we should have split it into
two programs a verified trusted
developer didn't yes it's just kind of
yeah sorry about that
I love these programs were waiting on
the new Google Play Store so now that
that started rolling out then I think
we're gonna hopefully be able to do more
interesting so hopefully okay well in
the last minute I will reiterate one
more time this is the last Android
developer office hours with the first
Android developer office hours in
January 2012 generally the 11th 2012
we've been going for 15 months I think
you'll see it's been at more than me
yes pretend more than me yeah in the 15
months yeah we've only missed a handful
of weeks and just have described three
to four three months until large we just
hang out with up to ten people because
hangouts on I didn't even exist in
January last year they came in and kind
of nice last year and that's when we
went online and started doing YouTube
live and I remember where Sparky having
to find his way around because hangouts
on air when sports in Germany you can
fly over every week drive out of Germany
yeah so we will be taking a break now
until after Google i/o I'd love to
Google i/o our new studio here will be
ready with a vengeance apparently so
thank you what you guys should all just
get together every Tuesday everyone is
there to just be like furiously writing
sliders I lost two times one time
because I will miss you till after the
Google i/o and second times because I
was not able to get the ticket to come
there I'm sorry many people saying that
yeah you're gonna go to an i/o extended
events
yes in my region yes honey will be this
official sponsors of the extension
extended Google IO and hope so we will
be there to support the developers
wonderful it was a great yes so thank
you to everyone in the office hours 15
months and and supported it and I wish
we'd kept a tally of how many questions
we depend so thank you very much do you
wanna round we know you will anyway
from us we'll see you too